is the administration considering more
aggressive containment options like a
quarantine a national curfew we're
coming out with strong suggestions and
you know it's becoming a little bit
automatic you look at people they're not
doing certain things people are self
containing for to a large extent are you
considering instituting a nationwide
lockdown at this point not nationwide
but well there's some point you know
some places in our nation that are not
very effective there Paul but we may we
may look at certain areas certain
certain hotspots as they call them
president Trump putting faith at the
federal level in the American people and
giving his own handling of the pandemic
a 10 out of 10 senior political analyst
Brit Hume joins us tonight good to have
you Brett thanks Shannon all right I
want to read a tweet that you had out
today president Trump's kovat 19 actions
have been sensible and in some cases
bold his White House virus task force
briefings have been extensive credible
and informative his own statements have
been rambling boastful vague and
imprecise they do not inspire confidence
so you say they're getting some things
right they're getting some things wrong
how do you uh well I think actually
actually I was young I would say that
today the president was much better but
he has a tendency to ramble he has a
tendency to say things in a rather vague
manner and this is a moment where look I
think the president gets criticized by
people all the time for the stuff he
says by people who ignore what he does
in this particular instance what he does
is important and what he says is
important too because there's a lot we
don't know and there's a lot a lot of
questions we have and a lot we can't
know and it is very important for the
people who speak about this the
president included to speak with a
certain precision and to be careful what
they say for example you know when he
said today that you know we this might
last into August well you know pretty
soon answering the foul she was up there
trying to straighten out that that's
that it could go that long but we're
gonna be assessing it on you know two
week basis so we can't afford to have a
lot of vague talk here and we sorta
don't need him to spend a lot of time
bragging about what a great job he's
done his head today gets a 10 out of 10
I don't even think many of the people
around him would give him a ten out of
ten but I think by and large he has let
them lead this and he has taken some
quite bold actions that shut down in
China was one the the ban on European
travel here was another just a cite two
examples so it's been a mixed bag but
but probably not a ten out of ten well
and people seem to have great confidence
and the experts he's got around him
these are nonpartisan people dr. pouchy
is somebody who's been there through
numerous administrations I want to play
something else that dr. Fauci had to say
when you're dealing with an emerging
infectious diseases outbreak you are
always behind where you think you are if
you think that today reflects where you
really are that's not where it's peak it
means if you think you're here you're
really here because you're only getting
the results therefore it will always
seem that the best way to address it
would to be doing something that looks
like it might be an overreaction
and what about threading that needle
because listen if you're talking about
trying to flatten that curve trying to
slow down the progression so that
doctors and hospitals can handle this
people talk about that being maybe an
overreaction of conduct so that you can
stop those kinds of things but then
there's this other side of it which is
the economic overreaction where people
seem to be feeling that there is a lack
of credibility there that what's
happening with the markets and some of
the decisions that are being made aren't
supported by the data I mean the virus
and the economic virus seem like two
different problems well Shannon I think
that there is I think there is some
panic out there and it's reflected in
the stock market's sharp downturn and
which which continued today and we get
to a place in all this where measures
that are taken to try to protect us are
regarded by people as further warnings
of how dire this is and the result is
everybody's selling I think the sell-off
has provided a golden opportunity with
people with a little bit of with some
cash some guts and some time but not
everybody has that people are scared so
they're selling it's almost certainly an
overreaction but having said that I
think it's pretty
clear we're gonna have a bad economic
quarter out of this and maybe two and
then we would be in what is you know
normally known as a recession two bad
quarters two quarters of negative growth
so those concerns are well-founded but
the president is talking about there
being a snapback effect and there could
well be because the underlying
fundamentals of the economy have really
been pretty good in the meantime he had
a briefing with governor's today and we
heard a number of things trickle out
from that people saying they said
basically you're on your own when it
comes to ventilators that kind of thing
but then we just heard from Ohio's
governor who said that's actually not
what the president said I mean do you
think that there is any ability for this
president to get a fair shake not for
not against but just factually what he
did or didn't say no I think there's a
problem with that you know a lot of the
things that have been said about the
response to this have turned out not to
be true man we had a pretty good report
today a piece today in the Washington
Post debunking the idea that he'd close
down the whole pandemic response team in
the National Security Council he
reorganized the National Security
Council and trimmed it down but the
pandemic response team remains in effect
the pandemic defense team remains in
effect that similarly with this claim
that he was that he was telling the
states here on their own in terms of
acquiring these vital medical protection
equipment it turns out a way of saying
if you can get it faster by all means do
so so you know there is the president
president doesn't get a fair shake and
even some of these governors with whom
he appears to be working pretty closely
who were Democrats I seem to be having
trouble not or at least their staffs do
not leaking out stuff from their from
their conversations it turns out not to
be true but reflect badly on the
president well as we've talked about
gavin newsom the governor out in
california has had nice things to say
about the president he is not a fan so
let's hope they can all work together
britt hume always good to have you with
us yeah thanks you